Five hundred million dollars
I could make your life hell
I'm gonna to tear you down
How straight are we talking about here whatever's in the way we got to dig through
It's got to be a totally straight line. Mountains? Straight. River? Straight. Swamps? Straight
Straight straight straight straight. Can I ask what the purpose of that line is?
Our purpose is to get the stock market quotes in like 16 milliseconds, which is 1 millisecond faster than everybody else right now,
okay
Then what happens?
roughly 500 million dollars a year
Why didn't you go to Eva Torres? Eva Torres uses human beings like disposable assets
I can make your life hell if I decide to
You want to buy a 12 inch strip off of our property?
Under your property!
It looks like they're building a fiber line between BATS and the New York Stock Exchange. I know Jenny I am looking at it
You're gonna do this, unless.
I already told you with can't
Oh, yes, we can.
Do you think she's trying to build her own line? I
~Builds her own line~
Just made half a million dollars in five seconds
We can't let her beat us
I'm doing everything I can!
Tell me your dream buddy.
Country home on a hill, small road, hummingbirds
All right, say again.
Country home on a hill, small road, hummingbirds.
I know you can do it.
Yeah
Okay.
"Ah ah ah, you didn't say the magic word"
Somebody rigged our network
C H A M P I O N
[Windows 10 updating.....]
BEASTIE BOYS - Do It
This is Palpatine's favorite jam
[Alphabet boi's approaching]
Mr. Zaleski
Mr. Zeleski....stahp
You betrayed me, you have to pay
Why is she putting up cell towers?
They're trying to screw us
I'm gonna tear you down
I'm going it's my meeting right now, but I'll tell you in two or three hours
Um, could you send all the paperwork over to my office? I'd love to have this done by the end of the day
Just think of it as David walking onto the floor of the stock exchange
Taking out these biggest slingshot ever and bring Goliath down to his knees
We're David?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're David